what's going on guys this is Rob and
this bumper is to let you guys know that
we are having a Super Smash Brothers
tournament this weekend on Saturday on
the discord server if you guys don't
know about it I have a discourse server
for all the comments explained fans we
have quizzes we have all kinds of
tournaments games things for you guys to
do and once every month we actually have
a kind of vs. battle of source where we
give away a Rob core ring so if you guys
want to be a part of that make sure you
guys check the link down in the
description it'll be a permanent link to
the discourse service you'll always have
access and yeah hopefully I'll see you
there let's begin what's going on guys
this is Rob and on today's episode of
beyond omega-level we're going to
discuss a character that's really been a
mainstay of the Marvel cosmic landscape
for decades in one form or another but
for whatever reason doesn't really seem
to get a ton of discussion and as you
can tell from the title of this video
I'm talking about quasar now there have
been several characters that have taken
the moniker of quasar but the first and
longest-running of them is Wendel Vaughn
the winner Vaughn was created by Don
glut and Roy Thomas as well as John
Buscema and first appeared in Captain
America number 217 and 1978 and as a
young man vaughn graduates from the
shield Academy with exceedingly high
marks but he was placed on lackluster
assignments because his trainers
believed that he lacked the killer
instinct needed for real work in the
field and so one of those assignments is
as a security guard for a research
facility where experiments are being
performed on a set of quantum bands
which had once been owned by a villain
known as the crusader well kind of an
interesting fact about the Crusader he
was actually created by Stan Lee in 1950
so over a decade before Stan Lee created
the Fantastic Four
but the Crusader was originally a boy
named Robert Grayson who a being of
Jewish descent fled the planet during
World War two
and what with his family to Uranus now
he lay receives a gift in the form of a
pair of quantum bands that give him vast
powers and he returns to his home planet
during the 1950's and begins a career as
the superhero known as Marvel boy now
later he be driven mad by the
destruction of the colony he lived in on
Uranus and then he became a villain and
tried to kill the Fantastic Four but
unable to withstand the sheer amount of
energy coming from the bands the
Crusader is ultimately atomized and dies
going back to Wendell Vaughn during the
experiment at the facility that he's
guarding a pilot puts on the quantum
bands and it seems that he's going to be
able to use them effectively but
ultimately fails in controlling their
energy now in advanced idea mechanics or
aim attacks the facility
Windell Vaughn puts on the bands and is
actually able to control
immense energy to defeat the attackers
and so as it turns out the same
personality trait that had made Wendell
Vaughn unfit for field assignments was
actually what allowed him to wield the
power of the quantum bands successfully
take that Nick Fury now due to his
easygoing nature he's able to allow the
energy emitted by the band's to bend his
will so that it doesn't break which is
what actually ended up happening due to
the stubbornness of the previous
wielders of the bands now windle's also
able to start fighting crime and calling
himself Marvel boy then Marvel man and
then finally the much cooler sounding
quasar now windows died and been
resurrected and is also lost and
regained the quantum bands in various
ways and at various times leaving others
to take up the role of quasar
temporarily but since windows seemingly
always returns to take out the mantle
again we're gonna focus on him for this
video
now quasars powers are all derived from
the quantum bands that he wears the
bands themselves were created over seven
billion years ago by the cosmic entity
known as Eon
now eons primary responsibility is to
foster all the sentient life in the
universe and he decides that life needs
a protector and so to that end he
creates the quantum bands and chooses
individuals to wear the bands and then
wield their power to serve as protectors
of the universe now the bands are
outfitted with seven jewels from which
their power is derived and they actually
fuse themselves to the wrists of the
individual that wears them so you can't
simply just take them off the quantum
bands grant their wearers a variety of
powers but their primary function is
allowing the wearer's to access the
quantum zone which is seemingly an
infinite source of energy that plays R
is also able to absorb and manipulate
this vast source of energy and basically
any way he chooses most often however
quasar uses this ability to create
energy constructs which can take any
form quasar can think up now these
constructs are incredibly strong and
have been able to destroy a meteorite
shield quasar from blast from Galactus
and withstand the heat of a solar flare
quasar is also able to use his energy
manipulation abilities to drain energy
from his opponents this ability also
applies to seemingly all forms of energy
as he's been able to drain energy from
the soul gym as well as other forms of
energy across the electromagnetic
spectrum now he was able to absorb the
energy shot at him by Thanos willing the
Infinity Gauntlet and then turned it
into an energy construct his most
impressive feat of energy absorption
however as when he was able to drain all
the life energy from ego the Living
Planet who recovered of course in his
own Beyond Omega
a video just a couple weeks ago now to
underline how impressive this feat is
the Silver Surfer and extremely powerful
being in and of himself tried the same
feat just moments before quasar and was
unable to pull it off now in addition to
constructs quasar can also channel
energy in the form of extremely powerful
energy blasts and has produced a blast
equal to 100 megatons which is twice as
much energy yielded by the most powerful
nuclear weapon ever detonated now quasar
also has the ability to fly at
incredible speeds having reached speeds
of 2.8 million miles per hour as he flew
from Earth to the moon and back in less
than 10 minutes he's also able to
perform a quantum jump which is
basically teleporting through holes he
creates in the fabric of space and time
this allows him to travel light-years in
a matter of seconds however he is not
able to use this ability while in a
planet's atmosphere without ripping a
hole in it now quasar is also immune to
psychic attacks and he's repelled
detached from powerful psychics like
moon dragon and so just to get a sense
of how powerful quasar is he was able to
siphon off all the energy being emitted
by Rachel summers when she was in
possession of the Phoenix force and
turned it into a hard energy construct
and the Phoenix is one of the most
powerful entities in the Marvel
multiverse and although the absorbing of
that energy pushed quasar to his limit
the fact he was able to do all of that
it's pretty impressive and while one of
the other users of the quantum man's
fire valve stated that the amount of
energy within the quantum bands is
finite this seems to be a matter of the
bands being cut off from their source of
energy in a quantum zone and so since
the amount of energy contained within
the quantum zone is theoretically
infinite as long as the bands remain
connected to it there really should be
no upper limit to the amount of energy a
quasar disposal and so looking at the
feats that we've run over as well as the
infinite source of energy that he wields
it's abundantly clear that quasar is
beyond omega-level but without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end I know it's a shorter one but
hey it's pretty straightforward if you
guys are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you guys later
Bruce
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]